this is the song that changed Kashi
Keegan's life
in 2013 he was working as an
entertainment journalist in London for
years he'd been trying to make his name
in the music industry he was about to
give up when he finally got a break in
Hong Kong and I would just report demo
after demo and then send it out like
unsolicited to different management
companies you know just when I kind of
let go and gave up everything happened
half a world away entrepreneur Ricky
Wong was pursuing his dream of shaking
up Hong Kong's TV market investing more
than a hundred million dollars in the
project Wong planty used this as my
dream as a theme tune on the network but
when the authorities rejected Hong Kong
TVs bid with no explanation the song
found new life the anthem for an antique
government protest there I was back in
England at the time just doing my
everyday job and I get all these alerts
like email alerts saying people are
uploading your song on YouTube this is
my dream was the most downloaded track
on Hong Kong iTunes beating even Lady
Gaga Keegan wasn't going to let that
golden opportunity pass him by he moved
to Hong Kong won a recording contract
and has just released his first album it
might seem crazy to some people like to
give up a life you've established for
yourself and you know a different
country and just up sticks and move here
on a whim kind of thing but they didn't
go too badly so far a song written in
frustration in the UK has pushed Kashi
Keegan into the spotlight on the other
side of the world proof that if at first
you don't succeed in London you can
always try again in Hong Kong's